so it's called the Josephus problem it's
based on on something from history there
was a group of Jewish soldiers who were
surrounded by the Roman army and they
didn't want to get captured so they
decided to to come with a system to
avoid getting captured or suicide so
they'd sit in a circle and the first man
would would kill the guy to the left of
him the next remaining living person
would kill the next remaining living
person with their sword and they'd go
around like this till there's only one
person left and then the last person
would have to commit suicide of course
rather than get captured and the story
at least the story I was told I'm not
sure this is historically accurate was
that Josephus preferred captured a
suicide but he worried that if he said
this the other soldiers would turn on it
and so he wanted to figure out where
should he sit within this circle in
order to be the last man living and then
he would surrender rather than kill
himself that was the problem it's a
little tricky so let's do a smaller
example let's say there were seven
people and so just to be clear the way
it works is person number one kills
number two person number three kills
four five kills six but now things get a
little harder to kind of see in advance
because seven there is no eight so seven
kills one three kills five seven kills
three so sevens the winter sevens the
last one left over for Josephus there
were 41 people he needed to figure out
where to sit the mathematical problem is
if there were n people where's the
winning seat when I learned this problem
I was in high school and it was one of
the first problems that got me to
understand how you approach difficult
and and math problems where you don't
know the answer in advance where someone
hasn't shown it to you in advance and it
was a professor of mine his name was
Phil Hanlon who played a big role and
kind of leading me to to math and he
suggested what we should do is we should
gather data just take various values of
N and just do it by hand and start
looking for a pattern I don't know maybe
we should just do that and is the number
of seats and W of n will be the winning
seat and so we know so far is that n is
7 w of n it turns out is also 7 and so
what I would do is I'd start doing some
other values so I don't know why don't I
do five so one kills two three kills
four five kills one three
kills five the winner is three I guess
there was no reason for me to skip six
so why don't we fill in six it's two
three four five six three five kills one
the winner is five so if you're watching
you might already start to notice some
patterns for instance they're always odd
I mean that's maybe the first thing you
notice and you could start as some why
are they always odd and maybe maybe you
can already see that right the first
loop around all the even people get
killed so so you can even with just a
tiny amount of experiments start to
start to see some patterns so you don't
want to see it uneven don't sit in a
tizzy
no no no and maybe we're even getting
some glimmers of other patterns but
before I really try to phrase those I'd
like to fill in the table a little bit
more so let's do some so if there's only
one person well that person is the
winner so that was easy
there's two people one kills two ones
the winner if there's three people one
kills two three kills one threes the
winner if there's four people one kills
two three kills four one kills three if
there's eight people one kills two three
kills four five kills six seven kills
eight one kills three five kills seven
one kills five winner is one all right
so it was one one three one three five
seven one three five seven nine and you
could keep going but maybe you can see
the pattern now I can write a no whoa no
good guess actually but it's not a one
so let's do 13 this is good I don't know
then I can see the pattern so as you see
it's jumping by two each time but then
it resets at some point and I want to go
back to so we'll see what 13 is quickly
so so we didn't reset that my claim we
won't reset at the next one either
14 will be 13 and and here by the way
I'm so we're starting to make
predictions it's worth noting we've even
though we maybe can't say exactly what
like 178 would be we're starting to see
the pattern well and so we could make a
prediction so so you could guess is it
really true that 14 is going to give you
13 and and we could do it out and you
see in fact it that's what you'll get so
so we're getting some understanding but
I want to go back to this point you had
you asked if it was going to reset and
go back to one there and and the answer
was no and it's worth looking because
because this is the next thing I was
going to do where do we get the ones so
if you look for a sec there's something
very special about the numbers they give
you ones it's the powers of two and so
maybe you can now guess that if I put in
a 16 I would get a 1 back and and
that'll be right and that's actually
going to be a real key in unlocking this
the professor I was learning this from
made a really big point out of this and
and I thought you know well I don't know
what the general answer is yes and he
made a big point if you know something
prove it and make sure you really
understand that one thing and that often
unlocks the rest so so he really pushed
us when I was first doing this to try to
state a conjecture and then prove a
theorem based on what we just saw here
and and so that's what I want to do so
here's the conjecture is that if n is a
pure power of 2 then the winning C is 1
I want to think about this for a second
and maybe see why this might be true so
let's do the next biggest power of 2
maybe the biggest one I can bother
writing down so let's do 16 so I want to
do one pass through the circle take out
all the evens take out all the ethan's
and now 15 has just killed 16 I'm gonna
put a little dot here so we remember
it's number ones turn again and it's
number ones turn again and we've removed
all the evens and what's left is
therefore exactly half as many so if I
relabeled at this point you can see that
it was a power of 2 to start with I
passed through the circle once I get rid
of all the evens I have half as many and
I'm back at number ones turn so now if I
do this again the same thing ought to
happen right I should kill all the evens
under the new labeling and now there are
4 people left and it's still number ones
turn so you go through again kill those
guys there's two people left it's still
number ones turn and now one kills that
and it's still number ones turn and that
chair wins so let's say we believe that
we know what happens for two
so how do we explain what happens
between the pure powers of two if you
see that the pattern you know we know
what happens at eight and we know what
happens at four but between them it goes
up by twos until at this point if I
added two to seven I'd have a nine which
would be too big anyway so so that's our
reset but we knew it was going to Reese
X it's a pure power of two so how do we
explain this jumping by two phenomena in
between and so what I'm going to do I'm
going to just mention that for any
number you can write it as a big power
of two plus something else take the
biggest power of two you can subtract
from a number and then what's left
should be smaller than that when you
express a number in binary notation you
choose zeros or ones and that gives it
as a sum of a bunch of powers of two and
you just choose the biggest one so
seventy-seven the biggest power of two I
can get is 64 and then what is it it's
64 plus 13 so then for 13 the biggest
power of 2 is 8 plus 4 plus 1 did I do
this right 7277 there you go and these
are all powers of 2 and this is unique
this is the unique way to write 77 as a
sum of of powers of 2 where no power is
repeated that's a key point so if you
wanted to take a general number make the
biggest power of 264 and then the
remaining part 1213 I'm going to call
this part 2 to the a and the remaining
part I'm going to call L and I claim
that this L is going to tell us which of
those odd numbers between is going to
show up so let's see how how about we do
13 and is 13 this is the binary
expansion but using our new method the 8
will be the 2 to the a and the 5 which
is the 4 plus 1 that'll be the F and
here's the thing that's going to happen
with the L I'm going to do five steps so
one kills 2 3 kills 4 5 kills 6 7 kills
8 9 kills 10 so now I've dropped L
people and if number 11s turn now watch
what happens how many people are left
well what's left is a power of 2 and we
know who wins in a power of 2 it's
whoever starts the first killer so now
if we go 4
here I claim that 11 is going to win and
just watch it's going to be 11 kills 12
13 kills 1 3 kills 5 7 kills 9 back to
11 and now there's only four people left
11 kills 33 kills 7 back to 11 2 people
11 wins and so this is really the key to
the final answer which is if you've
written your number as 2 to the a plus L
after L steps whose ever turn it is is
going to win because it's going to be
their turn there'll be a power of 2 left
and and so the winning seat will be a 2
l plus 1 if you write it in this way
because that's whose turn it'll be after
L steps the theorem or the claim is that
if you've written n in this way so if n
is 2 to the a plus L where L is less
than 2 to the a it has to be strictly
smaller so in other words 2 to the a is
the biggest power that sat inside of n
then the winning seat is going to be 2 L
plus 1 so we've already seen it was true
here right L was 5 and the winning seat
was 11 which is 2 times 5 plus 1 and if
you start going back through you'll
you'll see the same thing for all the
answers we've already really Illustrated
the mechanism which is after L steps
it's the turn of person 2 L plus 1 and
after L steps there are a power of 2
number of people left and when there's a
power of 2 people the first person the
first person who kills that's that's
who's going to be the winner let's see
if Brady has learned all right let's do
it
I think I follow now in the in the
josephus problem yep there was Josephus
and 40 soldiers that's right oh yeah we
got to go back and do that alright so
we've got 41 people so n is 41 now I
think expressing that in the way you
told me to it's going to be 32 plus 9
there you go
32 plus 9 so 2 lots of 9 plus 1 mm-hmm
is 19 there we go so we want to sit in
position 19 there you go you want to sit
in the 19th chair so here we go we're
going to do N equals 41 put them in in
the cave waiting their fate not a very
good circle but
I know should i redo this not you okay
forty forty-one okay there there we are
so it got a little tight at the end this
is this is a lesson about planning ahead
yeah okay so let's let's do it one kills
to five we're losing our even numbers
yep
okay now forty one kills one kills five
the 19 kills 35 and there we go oh I was
right there we go nineteen although one
other thing and in this problem which is
kind of fun so this formula I wrote can
be interpreted in binary notation when
we wrote a number as a sum of powers of
two this can be re-expressed in binary
notation so what was this 32 plus 8 plus
1 so that's 2 to the fifth plus 2 cubed
plus 2 to the 0 and binary notation the
digits correspond to the various powers
of 2 and all the digits are 0 or 1 so 41
in binary notation would be one copy of
2 to the fifth 0 of 2 to the 4th one of
2 to the 3rd 0 2 squared 0 2 to the
first one of them here's a trick for the
Josephus problem which which I won't
justify but it's super cool and you can
try it on your own
the way to find the winning solution if
this is n the winning solution in binary
is you take the leading digit and you
put it at the end so in other words I
claim that if I write 0 1 so I take this
part then I add the first digit to the
end that number in binary code is well
let's see it's 2 to the 0 plus 2 to the
1 plus I skip 2 squared and I skipped 2
cubed and I add 2 to the fourth so it's
2 to the 4th plus 2 to the 1 plus 2 to
the 0 which is 16 plus 2 plus 1 which is
19 which is
exactly what the winning seat was and
and so there's this this super efficient
way in binary code to jump straight from
the number n to the to the winning
number W event so if you're writing your
numbers in binary code the pattern would
have been even more more quickly
apparent that cool yeah yeah very cool
this video was filmed at the
mathematical sciences Research Institute
MSRI that's the building behind me if
you'd like to find out more about them
links in the video description they do
some really important serious
mathematics here and they're also a big
supporter of math outreach as evidenced
by this video